I recently heard a segment of a researcher talking about how oregano oil and black seed oil
taken for 30 days could stop cancer. They said this person mysteriously died after going
public. Just wondering if you have any thoughts on oregano oil and black seed oil as a supplement?
Well, I'll answer the second part first. Oregano oil is a great killer of viral infections,
even bacterial infections. Black seed oil is a great killer of fungal infections,
so they're both really good. So I like them both as supplements. Are there any negatives to
taking them? If you have an autoimmune disorder, oregano oil stimulates an immune response and
can make that worse. Black seed oil, no, it doesn't. If you have cancer and no real
known autoimmune issue that you're dealing with, you don't have rheumatoid arthritis or
something like that, then your safe taking those just as a trial thing.
But to comment in the first part, a researcher talking about how oregano oil and black seed
will take it for 30 days could be the cure of cancer. You're just going to be careful of
stuff like that. It's just nonsense. You see that all over, then the guy mysteriously died.
Oh, right. I know who comes up with this stuff. I mean, I just, I'm not saying anything bad about
this comment. This is the kind of things that drive me up the wall with Instagram and Facebook.
There's a guy would be willing to bet whoever published this is selling oregano oil and black seed oil.
I'm sorry, but I'm mr. cynical, I guess, but it's a, these are the kind of things that I think give
alternative care a black eye because nothing is like this miracle cure. There's no, we're going to
stop looking for miracle cures. We got to start looking at, honestly, we got to start looking at
Jesus Christ as our, as our savior. And he gives us wisdom, like we talked about earlier,
and he gives us knowledge to use. But, and I know you're whoever has asked this question,
isn't buying it into this. But we got to understand the general public does. And, um, and that's sad
because we, we look to things other than Christ. And that bothers me. And I don't like it
that to me, if I was, if I was an oncologist, seed, something like this, I would think that all
natural doctors are a bunch of absolute quacks. Um, and, and, and that's not true. And, um, and,
and I, and this kind of thing does give that a black eye. Can a regular oil and black seed oil be good
for somebody with cancer? Well, sure. Um, but you, you see these all the time that this
cures cancer, this, and this, and the person died after going public about this come on. I mean,
I have gone public with 2000 blog posts about different things that can help people with cancer.
And nobody's killed me for that. Why would they? I mean, it's kind of silly. But, um, certainly,
you could try this. There's, there's no harm in this regular oil has no
downside for cancer. Uh, nor does black seed oil have downside for cancer. So these are
tribal supplements. If you feel like God is lady, you, by all means, you can give it a try.